محمد شاهين اسم في اخر كم سنه بيصدمنا
صدمات سعيده جدا في دور بعد دور من الا
انا لموضوع عائلي احلام سعيده لسوتش
بالعربي مفاجات وصدمات رائعه بيفاجئنا
فيها محمد شاهين لكن هذا كله ممكن نقول
انه زهر ونور هذا رمضان بشكل وشخصيه جديده
ومختلفه على محمد اللي هو ادم في الهرش
السابعه اللي من يوم ما بدا عرضه الى ان
خلص وهو مجنن الناس ادم هذا طيب وصبور ولا
قاسي ولا مظلوم ولا ايش وضعه
جدا
تتلكك بقى في الاصل
هو انت متجوزاني عشان تقراي من عيشه في
البيت اهلك
ما فيش حاجه مهمه واحده زهقانه وبتستني
روحها اكتر واحد كنت واقف جنبك في الاول
ولا لبست
نيش اي حاجه انا بعملها
على الرغم من انه شخصيات ادم اللي قدامها
محمد شاهين مختلف عنه تماما مثل ما كان هو
صرح سابقا يعني هو لما متزوج ولا خط تجارب
ومشاكل الحياه الزوجيه ولا انجب ولكن قدر
يتالق في الدور ويبهر الجميع فيه ادور ادم
والاشادات في على المنصات كانت اكبر دليل
ومعنى النجم محمد شاهين اهلا فيك يا محمد
ومبروك النجاح
اهلا بك يا ساره الله يبارك فيك ميرسي جدا
جدا شكرا على التقديمه الحلوه دي لا ابدا
انت تستاهل اكتر من كده يعني انت عيشت انا
حلقات يعني في البدايه حبيناك بعدين صرنا
متنرفزين منك واختلطت مشاعرنا معك وكل هذا
الكلام
اول شيء يعني انت طبعا قريب يعني انت من
هذا العمل والعمل نجح مع الناس بشكل كبير
ليش الناس حست انه هذا العمل حقيقي في وسط
كثير اعمال ثانيه بتنعرض ما حد شاف انها
قريبه منه قد كده
والله من البدايه خالص خالص يعني من
الكتابه
كاتبين سكريبت الكلام فيه حقيقي والمواقف
حقيقيه
والحوار فيه حقيقي جدا ما بين الشخصيات
يعني وبعدين
قبليهم بقى في كريم شناوي وهو
عايز يعمل حاجه يعني واقعيه حقيقيه
انا كان لازم يعني او كلنا يعني كل
الممثلين هم بالديكور برده مهندس الديكور
علي حسام ومدير التصوير مصطفى فهمي برده
من الابطال
يعني اظهروا العمل يعني
كل الناس
معظم الناس كانوا فاكرين
دي ده ديكور ومهندس الديكور هو اللي ماني
بتاع ادم ونادين وسلمى وسيف
ومدير التصوير هو اللي منور البيوت بالشمس
يعني قصدي نهار والليل كل ده يعني مصطفى
هو اللي عمله
فكنا احنا كمان برضو ممثلين يعني لازم
برضو احنا كمان نبقى حقيقيين
فاعتقدوا كل واحد دور من حته ازاي يعني
يلاقي الكلاكس اللي هو بيعمله ده ويطلعه
حقيقي يعني والحمد لله يعني الموضوع كله
طلع يعني في روح حقيقيه ما فيش تمثيل قوي
يعني
وده حتى مش يعني والله يعني مش عايز اقول
مش بالاتفاق يعني هو
كل حاجه طلعت كده يعني
اه يعني هو كمان يعني ما فيش اتجاه يعني
كريم جه قال لنا يا جماعه احنا عايزين
نبقى لا لا خالص خالص هو مره واحده يعني
مع كل ده بيحصل وبيزود بقى عليه كريم
الحقيقيه اكثر في في تفصيل في في جمل في
لحظه في يعني كمان في نفس الوقت انت الشخص
زي ما ذكرت انت بعيد يعني عن عالم
المتزوجين يعني والعلاقات الزوجيه والعيال
والكلام ده كله يعني كيف جلست اقنعتنا انك
فعلا مش طايق نفسك ومش طايق العيال ومش
طايقها لنادين يعني كيف اقنعتنا
والله بصي يا ساره يعني ايه ربنا يوفقني
الحمد لله يعني
كمان انا عندي خبرات كده صغيره
يعني الناس اللي حواليا اصحابي اخويا
الناس اعرفهم قرايبي
وناس يعني عاشرتهم من اول من قبل ما
يتجوزه لغايه لما اتجوزوا بعد ما اتجوزه
بسفريات بكل حاجه في التفاصيل دي كلها
تقريبا شفتها يعني شفتها قدام عيني
يعني الناس بتنفذها مع بعض يعني فاهمه
فده يعني فده يعني فعلا بالمبدا انت فضحت
اصحابك وفضحت اخوك مصر كلها العالم كله
على فكره
بقول لك ايه انا في واحد صاحبي يعني مش
مصري وحياه ربنا يعني كانت تريل نزل نصور
وبعدين شفت
وبتاعه وبعدين
ده بيحصل عندنا بيحصل عندكم ايه يا ابني
بصي ده بيحصل في كل بيت في العالم كله
يعني يمشي العالم العربي بس العالم كله
يعني
طب لو انت مثلا الان لو يعني انت خارج هذا
العمل وطالعت في ادم تقول ظالم او مظلوم
والله هو ظالم ومظلوم يعني هو ادم يعني مش
يعني اه بيعمل حاجات تمام كويسه جدا وكل
حاجه بس برضو وهو غلطان في شويه حاجات زي
ما برضو ظالمه ومظلومه هم الاتنين ظلموا
بعض وظلموا نفسهم
يستاهل اللي عملته داليا فيه
هو هو اصل ادم غلبان قوي
بس ثانيه واحده والله العظيم هقول لك ليه
هقول لك ليه والله لان هم الاثنين ما
عندهمش تجارب يعني ما خطبوش مثلا وفسخوه
يعني ما عندهمش العلاقات
هم الاثنين عرفوا بعض في المدرسه وبعدين
كملوا لغايه
لما شفناهم فتخيلي الاثنين دول ما عندهمش
اي خبره في اي علاقات خالص هم الاثنين بس
هو دايما الانطباع عند الحب الحب ينقذ كل
شيء بس انتوا في المسلسل خليتونا يعني
نؤمن انه الحب ما بيساوي نكله بعد الزواج
ههه
22 سنه
محمد نقدر نقول انه يعني انت مضرب عن
الزواج بسبب اللي شايفه حوالينك وبسبب هذه
الاشياء
مش مضرب والله مش حكايه اضراب انام يعني
عمري ما قلت انا انا مدرب انا مش هتجوز
الموضوع جاي كله بالصدفه يعني انا
كل حاجه
بعقلي وقلبي الشغل الحياتي
اصحابي اللي الحاجه اللي تريحني بعملها لو
بتريحنيش
ما بتغطي على حاجه علشان
مش بقول ان انا عارف ايه اخرتها في اي
حاجه في شغل او يعني او حاجه حياتيه بس
بحس ان انا يعني يعني شويه عارف ممكن ايه
اللي يحصل شويه قدام باب الظروف اللي انا
شايفها قدامي يعني
ظروف كانت مراقبه ليا تخليني ادخل في
علاقه جواز لغايه دلوقتي
السابعه اكد لك الموضوع بزياده لا لا خالص
والله العظيم ابدا لا لا ابدا بالعكس ازاي
دول الاثنين يعني اللي هم في الاخر يعني
ما لهمش غير بعض يعني يعني بيتفرج في
الاخر لو الجنان هنلاقي ان الاثنين لسه
بيحبوا بعض الاحسن ان هم يرجعوا لبعض
بيحبوهم في تعاسه والنهايه جت مفتوحه وعجب
هذا الشيء كثير ناس
لا بالاتفاق ما فيش تعايسه هم هم في الاخر
عملوا ايه اتكلموا فضفضوا
ده وجهه نظره
وبعضهموش سامعين بعض
انا حاسه انه انا وانت عاملين الان على
الهواء
[ضحك]
يعني انا وانت هنفتح قلوبنا وانا هحكي لك
على زواجي وانت رح تحكي لي على الموضوع
هنقعد بقى يلا نفتح قلوبنا لبعض
بالشكل ده
دكتور بقى يعني
هو حقيقي ههه محمد الناس كمان من وقت يعني
الاعمال السابقه ناس حابه يعني حبيتك انت
وامينه خليل حابه
العلاقه هذه او التعاون فريق العمل هذا
انت سامعني محمد
اه اوكي ايه فكنت حابه اسالك عن امينه
تحديدا
خصوصا انكم طول الوقت مع بعض يعني
وبتصرخوا
يعني احنا مرينا بكل
المراحل حبينا بعض وغيرنا على بعض
[موسيقى]
وهزقنا
فمرنا كل المراحل
زمان ودي تاني مره يعني يمكن زمان ما كانش
فيه مشاهد بيننا بس المره دي مفيش مشاهد
غير مع بعض ودي كانت حاجه حلوه جدا امينه
من الممثلين اللي بيساعدوا الواحد ان هو
يعمل حاجه كويسه
ان انا اوصلها وان احنا يعني نوصل للدرجه
دي من المصداقيه هي
ممثله مريحه جميله
لذيذه شاطره
حقيقي عينيها فيها حاجات كتير جدا
حقيقه
احب ان انا اشتغل مع امينه كتير وحتى هي
في شخصيتها في الحياه الطبيعيه رائعه ايضا
طيب سريعا محمد
جزء ثاني
صحتك طمني على صحتك قبل فتره كان عندك
يعني تعبت شويه طمني على صحتك غيرت اسلوب
حياتك شيء الحمد لله زي الفل
حاجات كتير
والحمد لله دلوقتي اتمنى بصحه جيده الحمد
لله
لا الحمد لله الحمد لله وسلامه قلبك اصلا
وهو انت مريح نفسك لا تتزوج يا محمد
[ضحك]
انت مش ناقص يا ابني ههه
والله على فكره ممكن مره واحده مثلا بكره
تلاقيني متجوز يعني عادي يعني طب اعزمني
على الفرح عشان عشان ابتدي القصه من
البدايه اشوف القصه من البدايه وسنه اولى
والسنه الثانيه وكذا والكلام ده كله ههه
محمد كيف اخبارك
طيب شكرا لك نورتنا نورتنا نورتنا نورت
نورت نورت كان معنى النجم محمد شاهين شكرا
لك